hi I'm Naz malicious a developer
advocate on the Android team and welcome
to this episode of dead bytes in today's
episode we're going to cover the new
printing API that was released with
KitKat aka Android 4.4 Android 4.4
introduces native platform support for
printing along with AP is for managing
printing and adding new types of printer
support the platform provides a print
manager that mediates between
applications requesting printing and
installed print services that actually
do the printing the print manager
provides shared services and a system
user interface for printing giving users
consistent control over printing from
any application the print manager also
ensures the security of content as it
passes across processes from an
application to a print service most
devices running Android 4.4 will include
Google Cloud Print pre-installed as a
print service out-of-the-box as well as
several google apps that support
printing including chrome drive gallery
and quick office so what is this
printing API well the Print API allows
app developers to write applications
that can print any type of content to
printers that can be connected over
Wi-Fi or Bluetooth or any other kind of
printing service for example Google
Cloud Print it also allows print om
printer OMS to generate print services
and distribute them as apks on the Play
Store so that their printers will plug
seamlessly into the framework so that
users can print their documents to any
connected printer the system handles a
transaction between an application that
wants to print a document and the
services that deliver print jobs to an
actual printer the print framework
provides all the API is necessary to
specify a print document and deliver to
the system for printing as an app
developer which api's you actually need
for a given print job depends on the
type of content that you actually want
to print for example is it image are the
images HTML or PDF canvas in print
enabled applications users can discover
available printers change paper sizes
choose specific pages to print and print
almost to any kind of document image or
file print services our pluggable
components that contain vendors
like logic services and so on these are
managed by the system and are
responsible for discovering printers
interacting with them and reporting
their state about what's going on to the
print jobs as a printer OEM you can use
the print service framework to provide
interoperability with your printers from
Android devices and and this is really
important you can build and distribute
these services apks which users can
install on their devices and they can be
updated over the air via the Play Store
which is pretty awesome a print service
application operates primarily as a
headless service by subclassing the
print service class which receives print
jobs from the system and communicates it
to printers using the appropriate
protocols the print services will get
print will get printed content as a PDF
file and may apply whatever
transformations they need to make to the
data so that it's optimal for printing
and print services have to implement ap
is for being queried by the printers
that they manage so now from an
application developer spective I will
show you how to use the print API to
quickly print content so for the
broadest compatibility Android uses PDF
as its primary file format for printing
before printing your application needs
to generate a properly paginating PDF
version of your content and for your
convenience we actually have helper
classes that allow you to very quickly
print web views and also pretty quickly
create PDF documents as well actually
PDF output so if your application knows
how to draw the content it can quickly
create a PDF for printing now if you
want to print a bitmap it's actually
very easy to do this with very little
code you can print out images and the
only one option you have to think about
is whether you want the the printed
output to scale to fit or scale to fail
the actual printed page so what's the
difference scale to fit make sure that
your bitmap fits within the maximum
dimensions of the printed output page so
with a square bitmap on a rectangular
page it actually results in white space
on the top and the bottom of the page as
you can see in this example scaled to
fill on the other hand make sure that
your bitmap is scaled to fill as much of
the printed output page as possible and
this might mean that some portions of
the image are not actually printed
because they exceeded the bounds of the
printed page again as you can see
the example so here's actually here's
here's some code that shows you how easy
it is to actually do this so again the
only option that you really need to be
mindful off is what parameter to pass
the get scale mode method so once the
print that bitmap method is called no
further action from your app is required
the Android modal dialog box for
printing appears and allows the user to
select the printer and whatever print
options they want the user can then
print the image or cancel the action if
they choose to print the image then a
print job is created and a printing
notification appears in the system bar
now let's say you wanted to print some
HTML content so here's some code that
will show you how to do that the first
thing you do is you can generate some
HTML put in the string then load that in
a webview and finally attach a webview
client to the webview so that once the
content is actually loaded you can
submit the print job to the printer
vyses so if you want to include graphics
in your HTML content just place them in
the assets directory of your project and
specify the path to this folder as a
parameter to the load data with base URL
method instead of passing knowledge we
did in this example you can also load an
actual web page for printing just by
replacing load data with base method
call with load URL and this is very
convenient if you actually have HTML
content that you've generated on the
server side now there are a few
limitations of using HTML printing and
one is you cannot add headers or footers
and this includes page numbers also the
user can't specify print ranges so for
example you can't print page 2 to 4 of a
10 page HTML document and also an
instance of webview can only process one
print job at a time and finally web Roo
printing from JavaScript is not yet
supported for example window dot print
JavaScript call will not work we are
planning to address these limitations
and future releases and please free it
please feel free to open Android open
source bugs for features that you feel
are important that are missing or
changes that you want to see because
it's valuable this feedback is very
valuable to us so finally there is a PDF
document class which allows you to very
quickly generate PDF content you
using the platform drawing api's so this
new PDF document API offers a convenient
way for you to do this by getting a
canvas object by calling the get canvas
method on PDF document once you have the
canvas you can draw your printable
content on it using the standard
graphics API on Android and when you're
done drawing your content you simply
submit the document to the printing
subsystem and it will just print so
finally this this devbyte has been a
quick overview of all that's available
if you want more information we actually
have a training guide called printing a
document on developer.android.com thank
you for joining us today take care